I'll take a look at the smaller layout
first box a takes up fifty percent of
the viewport and has an order of
negative one which looks like it's the
lowest meaning box a comes first that
probably means the red box is box a
container to has a width of fifty
percent and no order so I think it's
probably a good guess that container to
is talking about the light blue and the
green dibs I can see that box be must
come after box a and because this
doesn't have an order it's probably
order 0 so that means that box be is
going to be the dark blue box that
probably means the green box is Boxxy
but I want to take out the larger view
port to confirm my suspicions I can see
that box see has an order of negative 1
in a larger view port which means that
it looks like it's going to come first
that's a pretty good argument that the
green box is Boxxy but let's just go
ahead and make sure Box B has a width of
25% in an order of 2 which is the
largest one I see here so it's probably
going to come last well that seems to
make sense because I said that the dark
blue box is Box B and here box be seems
to be well the last one box a is
twenty-five percent in comes right
before Box B which makes it the red one
so I'm feeling pretty good about my
answer that the red box is box at and
lastly there's still this container
class with a width of fifty percent and
it looks like it's still being applied
to the light blue and the green boxes so
in the end box a is red box see is green
and Box B is dark blue